you see I believe that life is really
very simple what we give out we get back
and what we believe about ourselves
becomes true for us our thinking creates
our experiences there is a law of
thinking like everything else like all
of nature there is a universal energy or
law of mind or subconscious mind
whatever you want to call it but to me
it means the power that is within me and
around me transforms my thoughts into
experiences you see I believe that we
are all responsible for everything in
our lives every thought we think and
every word we speak is creating our
experiences our future and it's almost
as though every time you think a thought
or you speak a word that Universal
intelligence or energy is listening or
responding to what you are thinking or
believing or saying without judgment or
criticism totally accepting us at our
own value whatever we choose to believe
becomes true for us
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because in my first
business I struggled to believe in
myself I quit on my business partner and
the thing that saved me was watching the
successful stories of entrepreneurs they
gave me the inspiration to keep going as
well as the strategies of what to do and
quite honestly I still need their
stories and motivation today as well so
today let's live your best believe life
and learn how you can attract things
into your life quickly enjoy
rule number two is believe your
visualization with Rhonda Byrne it also
said how do I believe my visualization I
visualize but I don't really believe in
it okay so are you putting you in the
picture with the visualization
um because I want you to know that
there's not really any difference
between you walking around in this world
here this is for Law of Attraction no
difference to that or you imagining in
your mind there's no difference it
doesn't know any difference between the
two so if you're if you're visualizing
it Law of Attraction for Law of
Attraction this is something that you
you already have
and and so if you're not really
believing it it just kind of means you
need to do it some more right and um and
and try and come up with some scenarios
that are really believable to you like
one of the things I would always do to
manifest and I don't know why it just
worked for me I defaulted to this I
would I would imagine I would imagine
telling somebody what I manifested that
it had already manifested so I would
imagine those phone calls I would
imagine talking to a friend I would
imagine people saying you know saying to
me wow how did you get that where did
you get that so that was really
believable to me but if because if you
really want something then you're going
to want to share it with family and
friends and and so that really worked
incredibly well for me so maybe that
might work for you give that a try rule
number three is eliminate the money
Roblox with Jack Canfield everybody
wants to enjoy a certain level of wealth
and success in life life but so few of
us actually managed to create the life
of ease and abundance that we long for
so why is that well one big reason is
because we don't cultivate a healthy
relationship with money we develop
beliefs attitudes and habits about money
in our youth that hold us back from
being able to generate wealth and enjoy
the Financial Freedom we desire when we
become adults now but the good news is
this once you're able to identify these
money roadblocks in your own habits and
behaviors you will be able to overcome
them once and for all and finally be
able to make more than enough money to
create the life of your dreams
now the first roadblock to wealth
building is any self-limiting beliefs
you might have about money
perhaps as a child you were encouraged
to believe ideas like there's never
enough money to go around money doesn't
grow on trees wanting a lot of money is
selfish or even money is the root of all
evil now these childhood beliefs can
hinder your adult financial success if
you think the money is evil and wanting
a lot of money is selfish you'll be far
more likely to avoid opportunities to
make more money and if you think there's
never enough money to go around you'll
be more likely to throw your money away
on frivolous purchases because who knows
when you'll ever get another chance to
do that again or buy that again
so if you want to Achieve Financial
Freedom the first thing you need to do
is some mindset work to change the way
you think about money now here's a
simple process to help you do this first
write down your limiting belief or
beliefs in your journal or notebook for
example your limiting belief might be
true artists don't care about money or I
don't deserve to be wealthy so be honest
with yourself and identify exactly what
beliefs you have and how they make you
feel
and once you've written down your
negative belief write down all of the
reason why it's not actually true for
example many artists have achieved great
wealth in their lifetime think of
Picasso and David hockney and
singer-songwriters like Leonard Cohen
Paul McCartney and Kendrick Lamar and
the belief people are willing to pay
good money for art they love I know I've
spent twenty thousand dollars on one
piece of art and others have paid
Millions
now there's a new belief you can have I
am a good person who devotes so much of
my time to helping others and I deliver
a lot of value and I'm always ready to
do whatever it takes to get the job done
well
and then repeat these new beliefs as
affirmations to yourself several times a
day to shift your Consciousness around
money
now you can also print them out and post
them on your bathroom mirror your
refrigerator next to your computer
anywhere where you're going to see them
on a regular basis and finally write a
positive turnaround statement that is
the opposite of your original belief it
is based on the reasoning you used in
step two for example instead of saying
two artists don't care about money say I
am a true artist my art is valuable and
I deserve to be paid good money for it
or instead of saying I don't deserve to
be wealthy you can say I am a good
person who works hard I care about
others and I deserve all the money I
desire
then repeat this new belief to yourself
several times a day for at least 30 days
this is a powerful way to create a much
more positive and powerful money mindset
the second big roadblock that holds
people back from making more money is
relying on a single limited source of
income for example if you have a job or
a career that doesn't pay much and
offers a little opportunity for growth
and that's your only source of income
you're going to find it a lot more
challenging to accumulate wealth so you
should either get the training you need
to be compensated for a higher paying
job or develop what we call multiple
streams of income to generate more
wealth for example let's say you're a
high school teacher you're going to find
it very challenging to become a
millionaire or a multi-millionaire if
you rely on your teacher's salary as
your only source of money that's not to
say you can't become a millionaire you
can choose to run a lucrative side
business in the summer or invest in
rental properties or learn how to manage
and invest your money extremely
effectively you can also join a network
marketing company and supplement your
income through direct selling and
rolling people in your downline in the
evenings and on the weekends there are
any numbers of ways you can grow wealth
and if you want Financial Freedom you
should explore every option and develop
a number of different income streams
that allow you to accumulate the wealth
you desire
now the third row block to wealth is
financial illiteracy by that I mean you
simply don't know what it takes to make
manage and grow your money and this is
essential information if you want to be
wealthy if you want to be a baker you
have to learn how to bake bread and
pastries you have to know exactly what
to do with the flour the salt the yeast
and so on and if you want to be
wealthier you have to learn how to make
manage and grow money you have to know
what to do with your paychecks your
bills your savings account your
Investments and so on now one of the
cornerstones of financial literacy is
knowing how to develop and stick to a
budget budgeting allows you to track
your money where it comes from where it
goes and how much you spend on all of
your monthly expenses this is super
important because it makes it easy for
you to identify areas where you're
spending too much so you can stop
overspending and invest that money in
your future instead you know most people
have no idea where their money goes they
don't know what their net wealth worth
is they don't know how much money they
need to retire so make sure you become
literate about financial things I also
want you to make sure you set weekly
monthly and yearly financial goals for
yourself in terms of how much you want
to earn spend and save and when you have
clear goals you are way more likely to
plan for them and Achieve them also
teach yourself the power of compound
interest if you make a loan or deposit
compound interest is the money added to
the original principle some of your
investment and rather than taking out
your interest in spending it you can see
simply let it be reinvested into the
account to earn even more interest is
the overall invested amount becomes
larger and larger gaining more and more
interest
now the fourth roadblock to wealth is
debt most of us in America and in many
other developed countries around the
world are carrying way too much debt and
the interest we pay on that debt not to
mention the pressure of all that money
needing to be paid back robs us of our
ability to generate lasting wealth so if
you want to be wealthy your first
priority should be to clear up your debt
and stop paying all that unnecessary
money and interest to Banks and credit
card companies you also need to learn
the difference between good debt and bad
debt good debt is debt that is taken on
to improve your future in some
significant way for example buying a
property that is sure to grow in value
over time
bad debt on the other hand is debt that
doesn't Advance your future in any way
but only cost you money for example over
expending on your credit card or buying
a brand new car you can't afford and
then having to make high monthly
payments on it for years and years to
come
now finally the fifth roadblock I see
holding people back from generating more
wealth is discomfort over asking for
money advice most of us are afraid to
ask others for advice around money we
feel like it's something we're supposed
to know and we're embarrassed to admit
that we don't and so we never reach out
and ask for the help we truly need but
you really need to get this it's okay to
ask for help there are people all around
you who will be more than happy to give
you the advice and counsel you need to
manage your money more effectively any
financial advisor at your bank will be
more than happy to meet with you review
your financial situation and give you
some free advice on how to grow your
will or if you know any wealthy people
at work or socially you can take them
out for lunch and ask them to give you
some tips on managing your money again
most people will be more than happy to
help and rather than looking down at you
they'll be impressed by the initiative
that you're showing ultimately the
ability to accumulate wealth is in your
hands anyone can make money no matter
where they are in life but it takes a
positive money mindset the willingness
and commitment to learning what you need
to know and then the action on your part
to make it happen also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is activate the
power within you with Bruce Lipton the
body provides us with Sensations
pain love joy happiness anger whatever
it comes from this mechanism it's a
mechanism the the eyes take in light but
they don't they they don't see light
back here in the brain they say energy
vibrations
sound comes in my ears I don't hear the
sound I hear the vibrations taste that's
a vibration it's a chemical vibration
all of a sense oh my God this is a
transducer it takes life experiences in
a body that gives us vision and smell
and taste and touch and pain and love
and joy and I say and this is sent back
to our source so we came here to have
life experiences and I go at that moment
of Awakening I said oh crap here's a
major difference between men and women
men are not allowed to have these
sensory experiences and I'll give you a
reason but women are so women are
sensitive they and that's a way of life
for them they're sensitive and then they
go about but men are so insensitive I go
that was a program
we were programmed to be insensitive for
a very simple reason you cannot be a
soldier if you're sensitive
you can't kill somebody if you're
sensitive so men have been knowingly
programmed to lose sensitivity so they
can be used to do those jobs like
killing somebody else and I go oh my God
then I miss the reason for being on this
planet I missed the feeling of what is
love all about you know what are these
senses of joy and happiness I'm not
allowed to experience them as a guy
because uh that interferes with the
soldier job I go by wasting my life and
that was a wake-up call I said well damn
it go out and taste it and touch it and
feel and smell it and do whatever you
want if it's really good do it again if
it didn't work out so good then don't do
that one again you came here to have
these experiences why would you want to
waste your life having all the negative
fear anxiety all those problems it was a
choice
it was consciousness
but we didn't know that because we were
programmed to be victim
and a victim has no power
and as long as you believe you're a
victim then you manifest victim
and this is why I'm so uh honored to be
with you Jeff because you're
experiencing this you know this stuff
you're trying to get this message out to
the other people why to wake us all up
because we came here to manifest heaven
on Earth like Falling in Love
and I go now what about all this war and
pestilence and plague and and all these
things I go oh that's a manifestation
and we're manifesting it
you can live in this world without even
being involved with all those things you
just have to change who you are and what
you are and what you want conscious mind
versus programs subconscious mind and
when you understand this you become
empowered and I say empowered to do what
I say create heaven on Earth and then
people think oh you die and go to heaven
I go boy is that a big mistake because
you're going to get to the Pearly Gates
Saint Peter's going to be there and he
says well
how was your experience on Heaven he
said what do you mean I said you were on
earth right that's Heaven why that's
where you came to create what did you
create I go oh
I don't want to wait to the end man
my my mother remarried when she was
relatively older and she married this
guy who was I said curmudgeony guy he
was not really a happy guy or anything
he lived to be like 95 96 or something
he had cancer my mother took care of him
at home the last week of his life
essentially wasn't there he was just
comatose more or less in the bed and
then two days before he died he all of a
sudden his eyes opened up he was there
and he looked at my mother and he said I
didn't have any fun
and all of a sudden I just said holy
crap he's going to die in two days and
he woke up today he didn't have any fun
I said that's not me babe because when I
finish it's going to be that was great
let's do it again rule number five is
break from limitations with Mel Robbins
why is it so easy to fill out limiting
beliefs but almost paralyzing to figure
out an alternative think this not that
how many of you are having trouble with
this it's very easy to see where you
doubt yourself but it's super hard to
come up with the alternative thought
that you're going to substitute
well the reason why it's hard is because
you actually believe these thoughts
and these thoughts have become patterns
and they've become habits and they've
become so uh prevalent in your life that
they're almost like the co-host
of your life
um you know if you think about it you
are the star of your life but if the
supporting actor is a limiting belief
that constantly tells you that you're
not good enough or that you're not
worthy or that you'll never succeed then
it's no wonder that you believe it
because the co-star of your life is your
limiting beliefs and so it's not
easy
to change your limiting beliefs but it
is simple
and it begins with you identifying them
and then substituting them so the most I
think effective way of beginning the
process of teaching yourself how to
identify a limiting belief and then come
up with your own
substitute positive belief as a way to
change the negative pattern in your mind
is to use the power of objectivity
so write down all your limiting beliefs
I'm going to go through this in detail
in just a second write down all your
learning beliefs I'm not worthy I'm not
good enough nothing works out for me
nobody's gonna love me whatever it is
that you think that's that's bringing
you down and then you can ask yourself
this what would Mel say
if Mel were sitting here across from me
what would Mel say
another thing you can do you can write
the opposite of what you're thinking
and you may not believe it it's okay
because what we're doing is training you
in a new pattern and one of the things
that Angie asked is she wanted to know
what were my limiting beliefs so
yesterday we sent out this workbook the
best decade ever toolkit it's in your
email if you go to the Facebook group
best decade ever with Mel Robbins it's
also listed on the files you'll find the
download for this check your junk email
if you didn't get it but
um so my limiting beliefs
so I want to have the number one talk
show of the decade
and the number one talk show of the
decade right now seems to be Ellen and
so it's interesting because a lot of my
limiting beliefs I think are provoked by
the fact that I'm the newcomer in a
space that I have huge dreams of making
a market and dominating
so one of my limiting belief is
someone's already done it how many of
you have that one
my dream has already been done
so my substitute thought because this
feels kind of true doesn't it
somebody's already done it
and then my
substitute thought the Think This Not
That is well they haven't done it my way
yet
it hasn't been done by me yet
do you see what I mean so somebody else
has done it okay I get it it hasn't been
done by me yet
it's it'll never happen
it'll never happen how many of you have
that limiting belief it'll never happen
my substitute belief it hasn't happened
yet
so I'm acknowledging that it hasn't
happened but I'm adding on the yet
as a way to keep my mind in the positive
uh it didn't happen last time so it's
not going to happen this time
how many of you have that one
yep
this is what I say I wasn't ready then
I'm ready now
you know because it didn't happen last
time because I didn't know everything I
know now I'm ready now
uh I don't deserve it how many of you
have this limiting belief I don't
deserve it
my thought is if I work hard I'll earn
it
do you see that so it flips from a
statement where I'm bashing my
self-worth I don't deserve it to a
statement about
putting in the effort if I work hard
I'll earn it
oh I've got this story that I'm the Bad
News Bears that I'm literally like the
person with the worst equipment and I'm
the underdog and I'm underfunded and
why does it have to be so hard and why
does it seem so much easier for
everybody else blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah and I flip that into I love
being underestimated and I love being
the underdog
in a very weird way as much as it
exhausts me it also empowers me
um oh here's a here's a specific
limiting belief how the am I going
to compete with Ellen I can't compete
with Ellen
um
especially when she's been at it for 20
years she has uh the budget of God and
an army of people that are supporting
her I mean there was something she did
today announced yesterday on social
media that I was so like oh of course
and I was so jealous she announced a
partnership with Starbucks where she's
encouraging people to pay for somebody's
coffee using the Starbucks app behind
them in line
um and then take a video of it and
upload it they're going to bring him on
the show and I was like oh will I ever
get there will I ever get to do cool
stuff like that and the answer is yeah
she proves it's possible
and also I can take the 10 years and be
like and in 20 years
I won't even recognize the cool stuff
I'll be able to do if I put in the work
so take that jealousy or somebody else
or whatever and say it proves it's
possible not put in the work
um so those are some of my limiting
beliefs and that's how you can do it and
by the way if you can't do that exercise
successfully on your own Post in the
Facebook group and tell people this is
your limiting belief can somebody help
you come up with a substitute positive
belief so that you can think this not
that as somebody in your life to help
you
um and then what you do is when you find
yourself going down the route of that
negative thought it'll never happen
you're gonna five four three two one use
the five second rule to interrupt the
negative belief and then you are going
to insert the positive belief it hasn't
happened yet that's it I'm rule number
six the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is expect less with
Vanessa Hudgens how do you then navigate
it when you don't necessarily align or
agree how have you dealt with that
because I think that's another healthy
thing to think about I think we often
have this romantic view of manifestation
totally and I don't think that's what
you're suggesting but I think a lot of
people have this romantic view that when
you're clear you get exactly what you
want the way you want it I don't think
that's what you're doing no no no no no
no no that's definitely not the case as
well like I think that like everything
does come back yes not always in the way
that you expect it to exactly not always
at the time that you want it to but it
always does in one form of the other and
I like I I truly believe that and I like
see that happening because I'll I
sometimes I'll ask for something and I'm
like oh my gosh that's so funny that's
not like how I expected it to come like
like you know like I are just on our
Zoom like finding love ones
on a tiny little like screen not like at
all when I was was like expecting at all
but like it's it's the best thing that's
ever happened to me
um so I I feel like it always it always
comes back around
um but like the mindfulness is like so
important
the beautiful thing about monk life is
half the day is self and half the day is
service that's how you're taught to live
okay so the morning hours are for you to
fill yourself it's almost like putting
on mental emotional and physical armor
like that's what a morning routine is
odd days are tiring our days are busy
our days are draining well guess what if
you didn't put your armor on in the
morning and you're going out to battle
how many knives are going to cut you how
many swords are going to pierce you how
many wounds are you going to come home
with how many of you come back home
feeling wounded
I come back home feeling wounded
sometimes but guess what if you put your
armor on in the morning a warrior would
never go out onto a Battlefield
and life can be a battlefield work can
be full of conflict sometimes your
relationships can be damaging sometimes
your friendships can be toxic sometimes
so we are warriors in one sense and so
without wearing that so for me a morning
routine is putting on emotional armor
which is meant to protect you for the
rest of the day and that way even if you
do get pierced or you do get popped or
you do get cut you're protected and I
know that when I my morning routine is
at its best I feel protected I know
exactly whereas when my morning routine
is weakened I feel weak and so for me
the morning routine as I get strategic
about it there's two principles you have
to know
location has energy and time has memory
if you do something in the same place
every day that place now holds that
energy
and this is huge like it's it's just so
big and I'm grateful for that reaction
because people don't realize how how
powerful this is like when I meditated
in temples that were 5 000 years old in
South India it was easier to meditate
because people have been meditating
there for thousands of years and so when
you find a space in your home and even
if you've got like I lived in a 500
square foot apartment in New York four
years ago and I just had a tiny Corner
which I dedicated to my sacred practices
so if you you don't have to have a big
home to do this you don't have to be
wealthy to do this you can find just a
corner in your home that you dedicate as
your meditation space or your reflection
space so first thing location has energy
second thing time has memory and this is
something that people underestimate when
you do something at the same time every
day
you remember it and time remembers it
that's why we struggle to work out at
different times every day it's why we
struggle like why do we feel hungry at
the same time every day generally we
feel hungry at the same time most people
if you've got regulated diet you're full
hungry you'll feel tired at the same
time every day you will look towards
that coke can or that sugar or that
chocolate bar at the same time every day
and so when you're meditating at the
same time if you're exercising at the
same time so what I recommend to people
wow is your morning routine needs four
aspects and it's simple and I call it
time it's about making time in the day
okay so time stands for t-i-m-e T stands
for thankfulness there needs to be even
if it's five minutes five minutes of
thankfulness of gratitude every single
morning and that has to be gratitude
that's specific it can't be gratitude
that's generic so generic gratitude is
something that anyone could be grateful
for oh I'm grateful for the sky I'm
grateful for air I'm grateful for water
that's cool but it's generic gratitude
specific gratitude is I'm grateful for
the fact that I have someone calling me
this morning I'm grateful for the fact
that I can still call my parents I'm
grateful for the fact that I have this
person in my business who is having such
an impact I'm grateful you know it's
specificity yeah so thankfulness second
one is Insight I think this is one thing
that a lot of people are missing which I
recommend people listening to you it's
like podcast books and and make it
easier for yourself if you get this book
leave it open on your bedside table
leave it open on your kitchen table
leave it open on your dining table I
guarantee you you will read more and
what you read will speak to you and I
think people underestimate that that
literally like when you have it open and
you'll just flick to a chapter randomly
and you'll pick up one line it will
impact you and it'll speak to you so
Insight you need Insight every day m is
meditation and I believe meditation is
different for different people as monks
we did walking meditations we did Beach
meditations we did visualizations we did
breath work find your meditation
practice I give a ton in the book and
fourth obviously exercise which you can
speak to even more than I can I exercise
to keep fit you look amazing too though
but it's an exercise everyone needs to
find five minutes a day 15 minutes a day
of exercise the brain is a computer
that's a clear fact and it has the same
functions and and systems as our silicon
conventional computer that people is
watching right now and so here's the
Insight I get a brand new computer and
got out of the store and I push start
and it boots up what does that mean the
screen lights up I said oh great got a
brand new computer let's do a drawing
let's do a story a spreadsheet and I say
no I can't do it I say why not you got a
brand new computer you say not until I
put programs in the computer can I use
that computer
and so I say oh and then after I got the
programs and then I can type and I can
interface the computer but I without a
program I can't do anything the human
brain as a computer gets programmed
starting in the last trimester of
pregnancy through age seven because the
brain function is not high enough for
Consciousness most of the time it's a
little lower and I say that's what we
said Theta hypnosis I say why is it
relevant the answer is very important
how many rules must a child learn to be
a member of a family and a member of a
community there are thousands of rules
to be of you know a person in the
community like a an infant can't read
the book I go no the infant brain that
is actually like a video recorder it
watches the mother it watches the Father
the siblings and watches the community
downloads their behavior those are the
programs
after age seven a child then can work
the computer and do what it wants okay
so I basically say so it started in
utero this is how uh um a mother can
play music uh through her abdominal wall
you know put the speaker there uh and
repeat that music and guess what when
the baby's born she plays that music the
baby instantly knows that music or the
father talks to the baby through the
abdominal wall uh and repeats this and
when the baby is born the moment the
father says something the baby will know
which one the father is because it
already memorized this stuff it
memorizes what the mother eats ah
because of the nutrition coming through
I say how does all this work simple we
talk about the blood is the culture
medium with the chemistry that
determines the genetics and I go so why
is a relevant I say then whose blood is
the fetus using in development I go the
mothers so I go so why is that
irrelevant well if she's having an
emotional response that's chemistry and
I said she's feeling that emotion
whether it's wonderful love or fear and
I go so why is it relevant that blood
with the same chemistry of the mother is
going into the fetus I go why is that
Robin the fetus feels what the mother
feels if the mother is under stress and
the fetus is getting an experience that
life is very difficult up there if the
mother is feeling love and support and
everything then the life is easy for the
fetus it started learning in the last
trimester
but then for the next seven years it
does the same and I go so why is
irrelevant I go
once I get past age seven my
Consciousness can type on the keyboard
so I can program what I want and then
here comes the monkey wrench and the
monkey wrench is this the conscious mind
which types can think and you go so what
I go thinking is inside
you know if I ask you Jennifer I say uh
tell me what you're doing uh you know on
Tuesday yeah and right away you can tell
me but you'd have to think oh Tuesday
what am I doing on Tuesday I say what's
the point
the conscious mind when thinking stops
looking out at the world and the
conscious mind looks inside so what if
you're driving your car and you're
driving down the street and all of a
sudden you have a thought and I say
conscious mind just not not looking out
anymore I said oh my God I'm gonna crash
the car because of my Consciousness is
inside
that's when the subconscious when the
conscious is thinking the subconscious
is autopilot and takes over like so why
is it relevant I go now science is
recognized 95 of the day is the average
person's amount of thinking okay so why
is it relevant well if a conscious mind
has your wishes and desires and
subconscious as your programs is your
life coming from your wishes and desires
I go up five percent
95 of your life is whatever the hell the
program you got from that seven years is
going to play and if you've got a
program that's not supporting you then
95 of the day your behavior will not
support you because that program doesn't
encourage you okay uh I always give the
audience the same story for 40 years now
and you know the story but I'll tell
your community I guess you have a friend
and you know your friend's behavior and
you happen to know your friend's parent
and one day you see your friend has the
same behavior as their parents so you
really want to tell you're afraid to go
hey Bill you're just like your dad I
said back away from bill because I know
what Bill's going to say the first thing
I said how can you compare me to my dad
I'm nothing like my dad in the audience
laughs I go that's the most profound
story in the world right now I'll tell
you why
everybody else can see that bill behaves
like as that who's the one that doesn't
see it Bill how the hell is that
how that's going to control and while
he's thinking the behavior is playing
but because he's not even looking out at
his own behavior he doesn't even see his
own behavior yes so uh in his mind no
I'm not like my identical but everybody
else can see you behave like you're dead
you're the only one that can't see it
and I go so why is it relevant and the
answer is simply this we are all built
we all have beliefs wishes and desires
and then we have to say how come I'm not
manifesting the world I want how come
I'm not as healthy as I want to be how
come not creating the life I want if my
mind is the Creator and I go it is a
Creator but then I tell you which mind
are you operating from
and 95 of the day you're not operating
from conscious wishes and desires 95 a
day the subconscious programs are
automatically playing like what if those
programs are not any good I go
well you won't see it they'll just be
playing you know what you'll see the
result so I very simply I wake up in the
morning with conscious mind today I'm
gonna go find love today I'm gonna get
healthy today I'm gonna get the best job
and then at five o'clock you'll come
home and go uh didn't happen it didn't
happen and I go then what does that
person think because they're like Bill
they go oh everything's against me the
universe against me
this person is responsible that person's
responsible for not letting me get my
wishes and desires I go no
all day long you were shooting yourself
in the foot with your own behavior and
you didn't even know where the gun was
coming from it was in your own hand and
I say so why is irrelevant we have been
programmed to believe that when it
doesn't work we are victims of the
outside when the truth is no 95 percent
of the day we were playing programs that
did not support us and as a result the
end of the day we didn't get that
support but we didn't see it why
subconscious was below Consciousness was
controlling your life your conscious
mind is I'm going to be healthy I'm
going to fall in love and I go that's
great but that's five percent of the day
yeah but 95 I go I'm coming from a
different program and so when you look
at your life and this is a beautiful
part you can say what are my programs I
just want to help people right away I'll
tell you what your programs are and you
say well how do I know I was being
programmed before I was born I was
programmed from zero to one can you tell
me what program you got when you were
zero no you didn't tell me the program
you got a one no can you tell me the
program at two no about three you might
say oh I remember some things but I say
you've been essentially programmed with
no awareness of the program so you
didn't even see the program and now I
say so what is your program you go
I wasn't there now I give you the answer
and you're ready 95 of your life comes
from the program your life is a printout
of your program look at your life right
now and I'm going to tell you this very
simple the things you like that come
into your life they come in because you
have a program to bring them in yeah the
things you want Health relationship good
job your struggle you're working hard
you're putting a lot of effort in I'm
gonna make it happen I'm sweating I'm
going to work hard
why you're working so hard and the
answer is simply this your own program
doesn't support that you're trying to
override the 95 of the day that that
negative program is playing with five
percent effort going oh I want it to be
successful I go yeah and 95 of the day
you got what are you get from your
parent not smart enough not deserving
not good enough not lovable these are
things that we've downloaded in the
first seven years
and very interesting fact is this for
400 years the Jesuits have told their
followers the absolute truth and nobody
understood what they were talking about
I go what do you mean they would say and
this is a fact for 400 years they would
say give me a child until it is seven
and I will show you the man
what the hell does that mean the answer
is just as I said science has said the
first seven years you're in Theta
program
that's where you're learning then I said
but what about the rest you'll have to
go 95 of the rest of your life program
so if I can control the first seven
years I control the rest and that's what
they said give me a child until seven I
will show you the man meaning if you let
me do the first seven years of
programming I will tell you how that
child's life is going to work out your
personality literally ad is made up of
how you think how you act and how you
feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life your
personal reality you got to change your
personality and here we go again you got
to start becoming conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to start
noticing how you act how you speak you
got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back to thought a new thought should
lead to a new Choice a new Choice should
lead to a new Behavior a new Behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
right so then the new emotion should
Inspire new thoughts and that's called
Evolution so how do we get stuck it's
really simple
the stronger the emotion you feel from
some event in your life be it a betrayal
or a trauma or whatever yes the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
you pay attention to the cause outside
of you so the brain takes a snapshot it
freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called a memory so we create
long-term memories from strong emotional
events okay so is that true that I just
want to understand the maybe the larger
the event in terms of its emotion to you
the stronger of a hold it has over you
yeah well the more it's embossed in your
biology so some certain people have a
strong experience in their life and it
catches all of the brain's attention so
now they think neurologically within the
circuits of the past experience and they
feel chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event and you keep that refractory
period of chemicals going on extended
periods of time so that the event
produces a chemical change and the body
needs to return back to homeostasis or
balance but if it can't then the
elongation of that emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called a mood so you say Ed what's wrong
with you I'm in a mood why are you in a
mood well this thing happened to me five
days ago and I'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry I don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago I'm
having one long emotional reaction I'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves by living in
the past and so then you say to them
well well tell me the story now the
latest research on memory says that 50
percent of what we talk about in our
past isn't even the truth so we make
stuff up about the past in other words
people are reliving a life that they
didn't even have just to reaffirm that
they can't change right wow so then
what's the significance of this where
you place your attention is where you
place your energy period yes so then the
stronger the emotion that you have the
some problem or condition or person in
your life the more you're paying
attention to them so they captured your
attention so you're giving your power
hour away to that person right because
they're capturing your attention so then
there's an energetic connection to every
person everything everything in your
past present reality has your energy
connected to it so now this is the
significance when a person really
decides to be defined by a vision of the
future instead of the memory of the past
the hardest part about it is all of a
sudden becoming conscious and not making
the same unconscious choice so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lower the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back yes you're
calling energy back to you and we've
measured this and all of a sudden it
builds this bigger electro magnetic
field around the person's body that's
energy to heal that's energy to create a
new future with right and then if you
didn't want to lower the volume to the
emotion then just take your attention
off the person and every time you take
your attention off the person if you
became conscious of that you wouldn't
feel the emotion now the body though has
been addicted to that emotion because
you're using that person to reaffirm
your addiction to hatred or frustration
and if that person died you'd find
another one so then here you go now so
now you're in a position now where you
begin to lower the volume to that
emotion and the body's going wait a
second you've been you've been doing
this for the last 20 years and all of a
sudden you're just going to stop hating
and the body says well I've been
conditioned this way and conditioning is
based on the past so when the body feels
the the lack of that emotion just like a
drug addict it says hey you're off
schedule here so now the body starts
influencing the mind to think about
experiences that are embossed in the
brain that are based on that emotion so
the emotion now is causing you to think
in the past if we teach a person then
how to trade that frustration or that
hatred for an elevated emotion and
they'll say yeah but you know it was my
ex's fault or I got betrayed by my
partner in business yeah yeah we know
that okay so let's take your partner in
business or take your ex let's duct tape
them put them in a cannon and shoot them
to the moon now what are you gonna do
sooner or later you got to reckon with
yourself and change right so then teach
a person then how to trade that emotion
for an elevated emotion now trade the
emotion for an elevated emotion right so
you're going to give that up and you're
going to practice feeling gratitude for
as an example yes the person says well I
can't feel gratitude and I say
absolutely you can because you don't
practice feeling it you practice
spending most of your time feeling
hatred and frustration so now it's going
to take a little time to cause that
heart of you to bloom or your heart of
yours to bloom once they're able to feel
even the smallest measure of gratitude
where they start feeling appreciation
thankfulness
gratitude it's emotional signature when
you when you get something when you're
receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature
of gratitude means the event has already
happened or it's happening to you so the
moment you open your heart and you feel
gratitude well that emotion then is
telling the body that the experience has
already occurred and the thought then
can make it into the body because it's
consistent with the thought so now
you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific Destiny you got to maintain
that modified State of Mind and Body
your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's Cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can get
ready because something weird or unusual
some synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well I was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic where my co-worker sent me a
nasty email that I would say oh my God
God you mean you're allowing your
environment your outer environment to
control how you feel and think you're
back to the unconscious program that
you're the victim to your life you got
it but when you start producing those
outcomes in your life you're going to
pay attention to what you did inside of
you and you're going to believe more
that you're the creator of your life
unless of the victim of your life The
Law of Attraction definitely works most
people just get it wrong most people
only focus on the thinking part and not
the most important part which is the
action right Law of Attraction it's the
last five letters that matter
a-c-t-i-o-a-c-t-i-o-n six the last six
letters doesn't matter action action
action thinking about it alone is not
enough so
it's the two parts you get an idea you
want something into your life you want
to manifest something amazing you want
success in your business you want a
happy relationship awesome you want to
speak on giant stages whatever the thing
is that you want in your life awesome
you have a vision board amazing just the
fact that you're thinking about it
and believing in it is already a big
step ahead of where most people are most
people live in a Negative Zone most
people feel like their life is hopeless
that they can't make a change that
they're stuck where they are and guess
what happens they stay exactly stuck
where they are right what you focus on
ends up becoming your reality so yes
you're going to focus on your new goal
your new habit the new thing that you
want into your life amazing you believe
that it's possible amazing you're
putting up a vision board with it on
your wall amazing you're researching and
watching videos like this every day
amazing that's great that's the first
starting point but nothing happens until
you take action
nothing happens until you take action
thinking alone is not enough
again it puts you ahead of most of the
most of the world puts you way ahead of
them but you're still just gonna be this
super smart super ambitious person
sitting at home not achieving your goals
you have to do something I look at my
YouTube channel as an example uh my main
Channel I want to get the 10 million
subscribers that's my next goal right we
hit one we hit two I gotta hit ten uh at
the rate that we're growing it's not
fast enough like it's gonna take me way
too many years to make it happen so I
need to apply more pressure against it
so part of what I look at every day now
in my morning routine is I want to hit
my goal I want to get 10 million
subscribers on my YouTube channel right
I want to be you know one of the first
thought leaders experts business person
to have 10 million subscribers on a
YouTube channel it's my next goal great
writing that down every day doesn't make
sure that it's gonna happen what am I
doing right writing it down can lead to
thoughts that then lead to action but
what am I actually doing well I'll tell
you what I'm doing now one of the
biggest things I'm working on now big
new Initiative for my team is I've got 6
000 public videos on my my main Channel
and I told my team this week I want to
go back and update all of the thumbnails
and all of the titles across all my
videos
that's a lot of videos right that's 6000
videos imagine doing split tests on all
of those videos I asked for 10 a day and
so to keep people on my team are working
together to come up with what the title
is going to be and then the other ones
doing the graphic design to create the
thumbnails maybe it works the first time
but maybe it doesn't
and it's a big ambitious project if you
think about it we've got 6000 videos 10
videos a day you know in a year if we
did it for 10 videos every day we're
just over half of those videos assuming
that they all work out which they won't
so this is our test and if it works
awesome I might have that become
somebody's full-time job so that we can
do 20 split tests a day 40 split tests a
day 100 split deaths a day I don't know
but it's happening to action right so it
starts with the idea if you have the
idea but you're not taking action you
won't get results if you just have the
action but you have no idea you're
running around with a chicken with your
head cut off you're you're going in
circles without any clear Direction most
people
think too much and don't do enough
that's most people some people do too
much and don't think enough some people
need more planning but in general most
people are over planners and so watching
this video alone is not enough
it's a great start it might boost your
motivation it might give you an idea to
go off and try watching my content
watching Dan lok's content alone is not
enough it's the essential first piece of
the ingredient it's it's essential
surrounding yourself with people who
build you up who make you believe who
give you ideas you can act on that allow
you to feel like your goals are are
possible that your dreams are within
reach is super important I do it every
day it's why I create all these channels
I think you should too you'll notice a
difference in how you think every single
day if you are creating content and
consuming content that builds you up
but then you still have to go take the
second step
it's why after every video I have a
question of the day or I have a
three-point Landing question because I
want you to take action you need to
teach yourself that after every video
you watch up to every podcast you listen
to after every book that you read
that that's not enough you have to do
something about it I'd rather you watch
fewer videos read fewer books listen to
fewer podcasts consume less if you're
taking action on the ideas that come to
you because most people are just
professional consumers
and it's great that you're consuming
educational content because most people
are just consuming stupid content right
you hate your life so you go watch
Netflix all day when you get home for
five hours and then go to sleep right
you're a professional consumer but
you're consuming
uh wasteful content just entertaining
content
so you've already taken a step above
right you're consuming educational
content that's the next step you're
consuming educational content amazing
but still that alone is not enough what
separates the people go off and achieve
their dreams from the ones who just have
things on a vision board is that last
step of taking action so you're not
allowed anymore your new standards
you're raising your standards for
yourself you're not allowed anymore to
watch a video to read a book to listen
to a podcast to consume anything without
taking some kind of immediate action
towards it immediate action immediate
action it may not be the big thing
if you want to hit a million subscribers
on your YouTube channel great what's the
immediate action film a video today make
an improvement to your thumbnail today
reach out for an interview for someone
today right immediate action teach
yourself that as soon as you get an idea
you do something about it because that's
the only thing that you're missing the
only thing that you're missing is
momentum if you're watching this channel
you believe in your talent you know
you're capable of more you've got big
goals big Ambitions Big Dreams to
yourself the only thing you're missing
is momentum so to activate the Law of
Attraction pay attention to the last six
letters action and start doing something
about it you will never find working a
pleasure if you hate your job or you
can't stand your boss what a terrible
affirmation that is it will be
impossible for you to ever attract a
great job with that belief system if you
want to enjoy your time at work then you
must change your thinking I'm a great
believer in blessing with love every
person place and thing at the workplace
begin with your current job affirm that
this job is merely a stepping stone to
far greater positions
you are in your current job because of
the things you believed in the past you
drew it to you by your thinking perhaps
you learned your attitude towards work
from your parents no matter you can
change your thinking now so bless with
love your boss your co-workers the
location the building the stairs or
elevators the rooms the furniture and
each and every customer
this creates a loving mental atmosphere
within you and the whole office will
respond to it
I have never understood the reasoning
behind putting down or berating others
at work if you are an owner a manager or
supervisor how can you possibly expect
to get the best work from others if they
are frightened or resentful we all want
to be appreciated acknowledged and
encouraged
if you support your employees and give
them respect then they will give you the
best work they can
now please don't believe that it is hard
to get a job that may be true for many
but it does not have to be true for you
you only need one job and your
Consciousness will open the pathway for
you don't have faith in fear when you
hear of negative Trends in business or
in the economy immediately affirm that
may be true for some but it is not true
for me I always Prosper no matter where
I am or what is going on
people often ask me for the affirmations
to make the relationships at work be
smoother in fact for many people this is
a really big issue in their lives I am
deeply aware that whatever I give out
comes back to me multiplied and this is
true everywhere including at work
in the workplace it is important to know
that every employee and employer has
been attracted by the action of love for
it's his and her divine right place here
and now at this point in time and space
Divine Harmony permeates us all and we
can all flow together in the workplace
in a most productive and joyous way
there aren't any problems that don't
have Solutions there aren't any
questions without answers
choose to go beyond the problem to seek
the Divine Right action solution to any
Discord that may seem to appear
be willing to learn from any Discord or
confusion as it comes up it's important
to release all blame and turn within to
seek the truth
and be willing to release whatever
pattern may be in your Consciousness
that has contributed to the situation
know that you are successful in all that
you do you're inspired and productive
you serve others willingly and gladly
Divine Harmony Reigns Supreme within and
around you and within and around each
and every person in your workplace
when you know and declare that it's
possible to successfully operate in the
workplace according to Divine principles
then Divine love brings to you those who
can be helped by that which you so
lovingly do
now if you like your job but feel you're
not getting paid enough then bless your
current salary with love expressing
gratitude for what you do have enables
it to grow
and absolutely no more bitching about
the job or co-workers your Consciousness
puts you where you are now you're
changing Consciousness can lift you to a
better position you can do it
during your work day there are a number
of things you can do to release tension
here are a few ideas
one before you go to work every day do
this simple exercise just sit
comfortably and concentrate on your
breath
whenever you notice thoughts coming in
gently bring your awareness back to your
breath
give yourself at least 10 or 15 minutes
to dwell in the silence each day there
is nothing difficult or tricky to this
and it's worth taking the time
two write or type this affirmation and
put it where you can see it at work my
job is a peaceful Haven I bless my job
with love I put love in every corner and
my job lovingly responds with warmth and
comfort I am at peace
when you start to think about your boss
say this affirmation to yourself
I only give out that which I wish to
receive my love and acceptance of others
is mirrored to me in every way
refuse to be limited in any way by human
mind thinking
your life can be filled with love and
joy because your work is a Divine idea
remember to say to yourself every day
before going to work no matter where I
am there is only infinite good Infinite
Wisdom infinite Harmony and love many
people come to me and say I want to be a
millionaire I I and there's a great song
about I'm going to be a millionaire and
they read things like the secret which
says if you want to be a millionaire
just just wish it and it will happen and
that's not quite enough I've worked with
many many many millionaires and I became
on myself quite a long time ago now
never having possibly thought that could
ever happen when I was at school I was
going to be a nanny that's how much I
thought I could earn in my lifetime
that's what I thought I was meant to be
but then I worked with so many
multi-millionaires and billionaires and
I really understand
how to attract money how to attract
wealth I'm going to take you through
today
why you haven't yet become a millionaire
there's several things that will stop
you here's the number one you don't
believe you are worth it you may want
money you may long for money
but if you have an inner belief that
says I'm not worth it not only won't you
attract that money if you did you would
get rid of all of that so if you wish to
become a millionaire you must decide
you're worth it the more reasons you can
decide you're worth it the more you'll
have that motivation that fire that
drive to go out and make a lot of money
the second thing that will make you
become and stay a millionaire
is working out how much good you will do
with the millions that you make you see
Bill Gates what an amazing guy he says
that in 20 years malaria won't exist
because he is using his money to wipe
out malaria that's an extraordinary
thing and he deserves all the wealth he
has for that reason alone if you can
think of something that you could do or
the people you would help and impact by
becoming a millionaire the more reasons
you can come up with the more people you
can help the more reasons you will have
to become and stay a millionaire and
here's the third thing and this is so
important many people think well I'm
just gonna float around and manifest
Millions I'm just gonna sit at home on
my sofa and manifest Millions if you
want a job you go out and look for a job
if you want a new home you go out and
visit new homes you want a partner you
better go out and put yourself in front
of people and if you want to to make and
keep Millions
you need to decide what are you going to
do to make those Millions what gift or
Talent do you have that you can monetize
you may say that I don't have anything
but that's not true if you really take a
while you can find a gift a unique skill
set you have that you could monetize you
see some of the smartest people in the
world they don't invent a product they
take an existing product like James Dice
and he took a hair dryer
he took a fan heater he took a vacuum
clean he took a hand dryer and he made
them better and many many people take an
existing product to make it better and
become a millionaire that way it's not
about shall I invent something I don't
have an inventive mind I'm not creative
it's about an idea you may come up with
a new product you may take someone
else's product for instance shapewear
wasn't new and Spanx came on the market
and became a multi
multi-million dollar company they didn't
invent a new product well they sort of
did they took an existing product they
made it so much better and you can do
that too but the biggest blocks I see
with budding millionaires that are these
things one is I'm going to be a
millionaire I'm going to be a
millionaire and they're just trying to
imagine in the future and the thing
about the mind is the human mind doesn't
future Pace very well one of the reasons
depressed people can't snap out of it is
because they can't future paste and by
the way if this is making sense to you
please like please share please
subscribe to my channel and show it to
other people who also want to make money
why wouldn't you want to make money you
can do great things for others when you
make money but they don't know how
they've been deluded by these
manifestations we're going to sit at
home and charm on Shanty and money will
fall from the heavens we all know that's
not true so if you want money you must
be able to visualize but it must be now
you must be able to think of how you're
going to and what could you possibly do
to make money remember that woman who
changed the face of a floor mop they
made a movie about her and she became a
millionaire and she was a housewife but
one day she was mopping everyone you
know this is not really a good morph and
she recreated and reinvented a floor mop
and
has made him millions that way but
here's another big block you have to
work hard many people think well I just
manifest I just sit at home the best
plan in the world will not work if you
don't work so people get this really
weird belief that people who make
millions don't work they just manifest
it falls from the heavens they float
around doing a little stuff here and
there and that's not true I work with
Millionaires and billionaires and they
do work hard they work long and they
work hard on their way to success they
work a lot when they get success of
course they can take time out but you
see when you do what you love and love
what you do it never really feels like
work I love what I do I do what I love
often say I feel like I've never worked
a day in my life because I love what I
do but really I have worked hard when
I've written books I've been writing for
12 hours a day meeting deadlines I
travel all over the world through time
zones giving talks and sometimes that's
tiring I plan out my schools and I'm
there teaching but I love it so much it
doesn't feel like work but if you
believe you can be a millionaire and not
have to change anything or do anything
or work hard you will probably never be
a millionaire you have to work hard you
have to apply yourself the best plan
will not work if you don't you have to
have phenomenal extraordinary
self-belief and finally you have to put
yourself around other people who've made
money ask them what did you do what
happened to you you see I met Wayne Dyer
many years ago and he said something he
always remembered do not die with your
music Still inside and I thought wow I'm
one of the best therapists in the world
and I can't die with my therapy I mean I
need to create a course make a school
teacher to other people I was so glad I
listened to him
and I've listened to many people who say
the same thing I didn't go to university
I didn't have a charm background I
wasn't born into money but I had a dream
a vision and I married that Vision to
very hard work I kept going
please don't think successfully will
never get rejected they do but they
bounce back they come back they have
unshakable
unwavering confidence they have drive
and determination so take a few minutes
and just get a little notebook or on
your phone write out all the reasons why
you would like to be a millionaire all
the good things you could do if you were
a millionaire the people you could help
and then decide what industry you could
go into you're going to invent something
create something and some of the
smartest people create things entirely
by mistake look at what other
millionaires have done read some books
written by millionaires there are many
read Richard Branson read Felix Dennis
look at some stories of millionaires and
decide if they can do it I can do it
this is a template and I'm going to
follow that template and if you have the
belief the vision the work ethic the
drive
and the confidence you will become a
millionaire
[Music]
oh
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
practical steps to reprogram your mind
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there abundance is our
Birthright and everywhere you look you
see abundance there's an abundance of
leaves on the tree there's an abundance
of snow in the ground there's an
abundance of water in the universe and
you and I have the ability to create